all right well it has been quite a week
for nicki minaj most of you never even
heard of her before this week right the
recording artist has become a focal
point though after speaking out against
these vaccine mandates and the group
think that seems to be the big
motivating factor here we find behind
some of these many public officials and
media types condemning the unvaccinated
now she's not the hero conservatives or
civil libertarians wanted or were
expecting but as it turns out she's the
hero we got now minaj did not attend the
met gala last weekend because she's not
been vaccinated aoc is now facing ethics
complaints and possible charges from the
fashion police for her showing up there
kim kardashian you saw a moment ago
looked like she had surrendered to the
taliban and some guy named frank ocean
brought a robotic child to the event and
i guess if you can afford a 35 000
ticket you can buy robot babies too now
this used to be a costume ball but it's
also come to represent now in some weird
way the future liberals want where
everyone's vaccinated and only the help
has to wear mass now back to minaj she
later urged others who have not been
vaccinated to do their own research and
prey on it in a tweet she also retweeted
a clip from tucker carlson and that was
just too much for some people to deal
with like so many others minaj has been
attacked by the corporate media the
difference though is she has millions of
fans and a social media media platform
to fight back at least for now
don't y'all see that
we are living now in that time
where people will turn their back on you
not agreeing
but people will isolate you if you
simply
speak and ask a question
all right let's welcome in now host of
the reuben report dave rubin also the
author of the future bestseller don't
burn this country which will be coming
out in april and happy constitution day
dave
i guess happy constitution day to you
john and before you even ask me a
question here i just want to say that
everything nostradamus said would happen
is happening robot children nicki minaj
fighting the power over vaccines it's
all unfolding we live in special times
that's right it was all there on display
at the met gala i mean i don't actually
want to go to the met gala to go to the
met gala i just want to go to people
watch because it looks fantastic now
dave
one of these people standing up for
critical thinking here nicki minaj we
weren't expecting this um but i think
what's more telling about this than what
nicki minaj has to say is the reaction
that she's received so far
yeah absolutely look i'm not going to
sit here and tell you that i'm a nicki
minaj expert or could sing any of her
songs i like i like frank sinatra but
that aside what nicki minaj in essence
is saying which is that you should think
for yourself you should do research
perhaps you should talk to your doctor
you shouldn't be bullied into anything
that there's an endless encroachment on
all of our rights by this out-of-control
federal government right now i mean i'm
cleaning up a bit of what she's saying
but that's the essence of it um yeah i
agree with all of it and you know
unfortunately these days we don't have a
lot of people especially in sort of the
celebrity class that she's part of that
are willing to speak up so i stand with
nicki minaj that's not something i ever
thought i would say but i stand with
nicki minaj and just watch the way the
machine is assaulting her of course and
attacking her right now now it's it's
actually endless well i was a little
surprised to see joy reid go back for
another bite at this apple after she got
body slammed by nicki minaj the first
time so let's take a look at joy reid's
latest uh rant here she is what people
like tuckums and the ben shapiro's and
other right-wing bomb throwers want is
not nicki minaj to have free speech
what they want is a vehicle to drag as
many of her fans into their anti-vaxx
camp as they can they need and crave
authentic members of the culture hip-hop
culture
let's just be clear
they look down on that culture and hate
that culture and would never ever ever
support someone like nicki minaj other
than to pull her onto their team
now our team dave are those folks
standing up for critical thinking this
has nothing to do with race and as you
indicated i can't name one nicki minaj
song but if you and i were sitting at a
bar and nicki minaj walked in we'd say
oh hey nikki come talk to us about your
perspective because we want to hear
about this and that's the difference
between us
and joy reid right
sure i'm fairly certain i have other
political disagreements with nicki minaj
but it would actually at this point be
irrelevant and i would gladly sit down
and chat with her about any of this
stuff but to use joy reid's words let me
be clear joy reid is a complete maniac i
mean she is an absolute liar the idea
that tucker carlson or ben shapiro who
is an orthodox carlson
yeah yeah tucker carlson yeah yeah but
the idea that ben shapiro an orthodox
jew right is a white supremacist when he
gets more hate i mean they've done
studies online research about this he
gets more hate from the you know the
so-called alt-right than anybody uh the
idea that he's a white supremacist a
white supremacist is absolutely insane
but this is all they've got you know for
years they were running with that half
the country's racist now they've sort of
morphed it into half the country's
racist and they're diseased and now
they're white supremacists too it's all
they've got she's just an absolute liar
and john i'm sure you've covered it on
your show you know when donald trump was
president she was tweeting about how you
can't trust the president and you can't
trust the cdc and everything else that's
right because she was just echoing what
kamala harris was saying and by the way
exactly did we ever get to the bottom of
whoever hacked into joy reid's blog and
posted all that homophobic stuff back in
the day i mean that's still an open
question isn't it
you know as far as i know john our uh
journalists out there somehow never
finished up on that story i'll have to
check twitter yeah yeah well good luck
uh over there on twitter what a place
all right let's talk about a
constitution day
now back when i was in college dave we
celebrated constitution day let's be
honest we celebrated everything but
college kids these days aren't too into
it a campus reform went to gainesville
in the university of florida to talk to
students about a petition going around
campus down there and it calls for the
abolishment of the constitution take a
look what do you guys think of the
constitution absolutely terrible need to
be redone immediately i think it needs a
lot more reform it should be abolished
like it's time for
a new
constitution it wasn't like
pronouns like they them stuff like that
either so we should include the new
pronouns in the constitution yeah like
to make everyone feel included
so we're going to rewrite the
constitution dave it's now going to
start with
they them me he she
whatever
the pronoun they always forget is we
we the first word of the constitution we
still a pronoun right
we the people used to be sane
we the people ain't saying no more i
mean look this is just such an extension
of the disaster that critical race
theory that social justice that the
endless dishonest assault on all of our
institutions and our history has wrought
does it surprise anyone to hear any of
this of course yes we should have gender
pronouns in our new constitution the
constitution is ridiculous i can't even
laugh i can't even get to you saying
without laughing
look the constitution is in my
estimation the most perfect man-made
document to free people in the history
of the world it doesn't mean that all of
the people that wrote it were perfect
nor any of us that now live by those
laws are perfect but those documents set
up a country that for 250 years said hey
we don't care where you're from we don't
care what you look like we don't care
what your religion is etc etc you can
come here and make a better life for
yourself and john i do this all the time
when i'm at college events but i would
ask anyone watching this right now to
think about your own grandparents and is
your life better or worse and the answer
almost without uh exception is better
that tells you that this thing which is
based in the constitution and the bill
of rights is pretty good and the and the
fact that these kids are being empowered
by big tech companies and corporate
media to destroy
the most wonderful precious country in
the world is is deeply depressing i know
you know i think about your grandparents
my grandparents lived to the great
depression they saved every like piece
of plastic every margarine
dish was used for a secondary purpose
and now i feel bad every time i look at
my trash can at work and i've got two
uber eats
packages in there we live in the best
time in the history of mankind in terms
of convenience and opportunity uh and
you know the constitution was written in
a way that it doesn't change unless we
change it but things like we have
different meaning than they did in 1776
now it incorporates all these races and
religions and both sexes uh it didn't
necessarily mean that back then but it
means that now and these kids aren't
taught that you know you also talked
about you know it has to everybody has
to be infallible now if they are going
to be worshipped and humans are not like
that that's another thing that these
kids don't learn uh through all these
participation trophies and you're
perfect you living your own individual
truth
life isn't like that we're not perfect
nobody is uh but these kids want it they
want perfection well
john you know the interesting part of
this also is that this we shouldn't just
aim at the kids here because of course
everything you said is just right but
it's the adults that have failed them
you know like when i hear these kids
with the gender pronouns and sure let's
disassemble the united states and he
she's easier the whole thing of course
it's ridiculous but it's because they
were allowed to learn these things i
mean you know my last book don't burn
this book was a defense of classical
liberalism of enlightenment values and
individual rights and things of that
nature but at the end of purely secular
liberalism you end up with this you end
up with people living in the freest
society as i said in the history of the
world trying to disassemble it and not
even knowing what gender they are at the
exact same time and and those of us that
want to save this country we really have
to figure this thing out and soon
because the more that these colleges
pump out these kids that are here to
burn it down which is exactly what the
progressives have been teaching them
this whole time uh the quicker we're
gonna have to fix something or build
something separate or defend this um
we just need more of us and we have to
work harder right and that's the like
you know aha moment when you read the
constitution right wait a minute
this gives the power to me
from the higher power to empower my
government doesn't give it from the
higher power to the government to
empower themselves over me and that's
what i wish these kids understood and
you're right it's not their fault it's
the adults who have failed them all
right so dave when do i get my advanced
copy of the new book
we'll get that out to you soon do you
want me when i'm signing it you know i
usually i would write your name or
something but can i do a he or a she or
a wii or a zur or are you an autobot
what are you these days uh my pronoun is
bro i go with that so you can
just i'm just kidding or dude whatever
you want but dave we'll see you soon i
look forward to reading the book when it
comes out in april thanks so much as
always
good seeing you bro all right dude if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell